good afternoon my name is Velma Latson
and I am from Buie State University and
I'm going to give a brief discussion on
the impact of moo Blended instruction to
teach
programming um the outline of the
presentation will be first I'm going to
give an a brief introduction and
background of the study then a
description of the actual study that was
conducted a synopsis of the course that
was used in the research study uh a DAT
some data that was collected challenges
that were um that were brought up during
the uh course of the research study uh
some of the best practices that we
implemented at Buie State University for
the study and what I've actually um come
up with was what I believe is mastering
Blended instruction um some things that
I saw and recognized and were that
emerged from the research that I've kind
of put together and hopefully uh we'll
have time to do a group group
activity so Buie State
University is um the oldest historically
black College University in Maryland it
is also one of the 10 oldest
historically black colleges of
universities in the nation I've been
teaching at Buie State University for
about 14 15 years now I have a
background in computer science um
programming I have a background in
information uh systems information
technology and also instructional design
so I am also the course coordinator for
the course that we're going to be
talking about this afternoon and I am
also the computer technology coordinator
for our computer technology program um
at Buie State University and our
computer technology program is housed in
the computer science department so we
all have um uh merging disciplines in
that particular program uh Buie state
has about 5,000 students we're a small
uh University we sit between Washington
DC and Baltimore Maryland and our
students have a great opportunity to do
internships and research opportunities
for the federal government we have um
industry Partners Loi Martin north of
Grumman um Booze Allen so a lot of uh
our graduates undergraduates have a lot
of
opportunities in that
area the background of the study was
part of a um my piece was part of a
larger research study that was conducted
by the university system of Maryland
andth ethia Gates ith Etha Gates excuse
me and what they were doing were looking
at different various interactive
platforms to be used in traditional
University settings uh lecturing
settings and so this uh was funded by
The Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
and buoy was actually one of 10
universities that actually participated
in this larger study so what I'm going
to be talking about today is just my
small piece of the larger study that was
conducted during this
time so the course that we chose to use
in uh at Buie State University was a
course called uh Computing tools and
Technologies um
cc11 it's a general education course for
non- stem Majors two reasons uh I am the
course designer I came up with the
concept I proposed the course in this
infancy and one reason was we have two
general education courses one is
computer science 110 which is basically
word excel that type of thing and so
with conversation across our campus they
wanted a little bit more rigorous
computer science course so that's the
concept of 111 and so part of 111 uh CC
111 includes the six modules there uh
programming HTML they learned a little
bit of Hardware operating system
networking and we definitely talk about
Security in that course um it's also a
recruit recruiter course we try to have
students know that computer science uh
stem disciplines are not threatening so
we try to make it a a engaging course to
try to recruit students to our
program so the moo that we used um in
this was from
corsera introduction to interactive
programming in Python which was created
by Rice University and um we it was it's
an eight week uh Muk so the module
consisted of the eight weeks that we
used in the um course and
um it was a pretty good moo so we're
going to go ahead and talk about that
part the design of the instruction was
Blended so we had the moo we also used
face t- face components and then we had
our own on Campus Learning Management
System Blackboard and so part of the um
research we had four treatment sections
sessions that had uh three faculty one
faculty person Tau two sessions SE
sections and then our control group five
and again one faculty person taught two
courses um we had approximately 200
students total 100 in each group of
participants the team and who I directly
worked along with myself the course
coordinator I worked along with the
instructional designer uh the person
that was over buoy uh Blackboard
learning management system she worked
along with me we worked along with a
corser representative who helped us use
the tools who gave us access to the who
gave me access to the tools prior to the
fall semester being conducted so I can
review the moo understand what was going
on in the moo um we had full-time
faculty adjuncts and peer
tutors uh that was a part of this and
the discussion throughout was always a
conversation with everyone involved I
did not teach any of the sections
whatsoever I coordinated the effort um I
designed designed the course for all the
instructors to use in the traditional
course as well as the moo uh treat uh
treatment course and um but we were
always in constant communication
throughout the 8we module and actually
the eight weeks ran through our midterm
so it worked out really well because the
data that we collected was up to
midterm so just some of the stud uh
habits that we found out during um the
research and you can see it's even
pretty much across the board there was
really no differences in that um they
asked for help some some in both
sections did not complete the work as a
sign there were some difficulties so
there was really no differences in some
of the student habits in both
groups uh the moo itself um again it was
mid-range in most of the
um uh cross mid-range uh confusing to
have different instructors so that was
some of the students saying you know
they come face to face but then they had
to look at the mukes in order for the
instruction so some of them thought that
was a bit confusing um some believed it
was a little bit difficult to follow um
but across the board the mean was pretty
even on uh ranges of one through
five I like this make course more
enjoyable than face to
face so
um yeah bigest one so uh here for the
midterm grade alone we had pretty it was
cross the board you know there was
really no significant differences
between the traditional courses and
those that were offered in the moo um
the mean was 70 7 70% both for past
rates at the time of midterm and the
reason that's significant is because
that's when students have the
opportunity to drop a class so they
could withdraw drop a class so we just
kept that data and then we also uh what
was the midterm grade so when it says
final here it's just we're talking about
what was their midterm grade at that
point because after that they it was was
they were great it was like you don't
even have to look at programming ever
again in life you don't have to worry
about a understanding python so they
were really happy with
that so now some of the challenges that
we had was um using both uh the moo and
a Blackboard learning management system
buoy has our university has their own
internal controls so they wanted to make
sure that we made use of their learning
management system um they were not in
favor of a single sign on solution for
the students we wanted to know if we can
have that capability they said no so we
had to ask cor Sarah to give us separate
Logans for over 100 students so that we
can have access to their content and
then the students also had to log into
their own separate account yeah for our
learning management system so it was it
was a bit challenging um access to the
moo um I think that was more a challenge
for myself and some of the faculty um uh
of course sah allowed us to have a
canned Muk in which they I believe they
may have copied the actual Muk for us
because our students were not a part of
the larger population we had our own um
unique uh private Muk at that point
excuse me and so I believe uh part of
the challenges was uh setting up
assignments correctly the weekly quizzes
um not being really familiar with the
corsera format we did have a rep that
was there to help us through it but uh
one Challenge and I want to bring this
out uh is that it's a general education
course so during the fall enrollment you
know if you have an influx of freshman
the advisement Center say can you offer
more section of this course and then
faculty may not have met their FTE for
you know some of their courses were
dropped so right up until the beginning
of the semester we were changing faculty
you know faculty were bumping some
adjuncts out and taking over so it was
really a problem with um faculty
development and understanding the whole
concept of the moo at that time so that
was challenging and then we did have a
textbook um and yet the Python
Programming was a little bit different
than that offered in the corsera moo the
students and the faculty enjoyed what
the Muk the environment because it was a
web-based um environment for the Python
Programming and both the faculty and the
students enjoyed that so they were able
to write the code right and to a browser
and that was really good I think it was
called code
sculpture so now some of the best
practices that we did Implement through
this because we knew it was a large uh
cohort of students where we tried to
keep them together as much as possible
so we arranged through the advisement
that they took their freshman seminar
course together along with this general
education course together so we tried to
do that that that allowed for the
students to um help each other because
they were seeing each other before they
were actually go to the class so they
had their own peer tutoring going on at
that time then we also had mandatory
tutoring that was a part of it and the
peer tutors were always available
throughout the week in case they were
not able to get in touch with their own
faculty members during that time so we
were able to have that and then we also
offered supplemental instructional tools
um KH Academy and the
like so this is what I believe
um would great will create successful
Blended instruction now this is just
something I was bouncing around with
that it definitely has to be sound
instructional design for the course we
all agree with that and then student
Readiness and there are many check
sheets and things that go out about are
students prepared for an online uh
environment um but I also think faculty
Readiness is becoming really key into a
successful Blended instructional
environment so um and what what what I'm
saying is we have faculty on our campus
that may not be um favorable for using
mukes but yet because that's the
environment that our Administration is
leaning towards then how is it that we
make that faculty ready to use that type
of uh um instructional tool in the
classroom so faculty Readiness is really
key because of my background in
instructional technology I enjoy the
tools I'm I'm excited about what we can
do with the tools to help in education
but not everyone feels that
way
so at this point I any questions I will
open the floor for anyone we may have
some questions uh you have to use the
mic thank
you and I'm sorry and I would just like
to uh recognize Dr Jackson uh who
actually helped me with um she's also a
buoy State colleague who helped me with
the research and some of the activities
so I'm give me Pro sry
yeah so I I'm sash zberry I'm from Koka
Community College and um I wanted I just
had a couple questions about your
research design first of all I'm
thrilled that you had a control group
which we so rarely do in educational
research um did all of your
interventions including the cohort um
the mandatory tutoring that kind of
thing were those only for the treatment
group or were those also available for
the control group they were available
for all the students for all the stud
all the students the only difference you
were looking at was the moo only the moo
okay great only the moo and uh the
Freshman seminar course was huge it was
pretty big uh but the only reason not
all of them were able to get in the one
freshman section because some of the
Genet they're non- Majors for one and so
some of um other Majors May uh have
their own freshman seminar courses like
the nursing will have their own freshman
seminar courses and some of the bio uh
uh Natural Sciences they have their own
freshman seminar course so as much as we
could we tried to keep them all together
in a
cohort what was the reasoning behind
keeping them sort of separate from the
other moo so you said that they were in
their own little self-contained no no no
um let me explain course Sarah no course
Sarah gave us a shell so yeah cor Sarah
offered the course I believe
uh as a regular Muk but the course that
we used was not the same one that the
rest of the world was
using so that was a choice of corsera it
wasn't it wasn't our choice were your
students able
to were they were they on forums with
the
other so this was
okay that is interesting
yeah so Dan Garcia UC Berkeley so we're
trying to build a moo for high schools
in a blended way and so I'm really
excited by this work um you said your
students are non- Majors yeah um how
many of them struggled with typing or
struggled with kind of we're looking at
a block spaced approach rather than a
typing rather than a python style other
language as a blocks deriven um so we
argue that for students who just it's
hard to type fast and they pointing
click as I was for a certain time um the
blocks model might be better do you hear
it all from the sense were two questions
one is did you hear it all from your
students that just learning the text
based language was difficult uh just
overall that's kind of blocks versus
text not less about the muks um and
answer that one and I'll wait for the
second well I unfortunately I did not
teach the sections so I was relying
mostly on the faculty that was actually
teaching the section and when that
question never came up about whether or
not they had difficulties with the
actual uh typing right yeah um that's
really interesting interesting cuz I
mean my kids it's amazing like I had to
learn in Hunt and pack and then when I
was in like eighth grade I took typing
on an actual typewriter my kids can type
circles around me and I'm pretty fast
now because they're so used to growing
up with devices I wouldn't think it
would be hard for high school students
to
type totally sorry Counterpoint um I I
think it really depends on your student
population because we have a student
population that that does not really um
across the board have access to what you
would consider to be a personal computer
or even a laptop we have a lot of
students that their only computing power
that they own comes from a smartphone so
they have to go to a library or
something like and we have seen
significant challenges with typing okay
yeah but that yeah that never came up
with my second question was about
faculty Readiness Can You Dig a Little
Deeper to that what um as we're going
forward and working with high school
teachers now and there's a huge range I
mentioned this in earlier section a huge
range in their background in computer
science we have some people coming in
from art some people who have Masters in
CS and there huge range between them
yeah um tell me what it it's not just
I'm ready and I'm prepared and I've
bought into it but I you all of your
faculty have have the content knowledge
but some of us ours don't so we have the
buyin but not the content knowledge you
have the content knowledge not the buyin
so tell me what what what do you mean by
Readiness and more than just the
buying well I believe that they have to
marry I believe the content experts have
to understand the educational part of it
and and vice versa so and I believe in
higher education most
instructors are not education are not
um yeah uh I'm G just trying to figure
out how to say it delicately because I
I'm on the fence with with both of that
but um and I believe that uh the The
Faculty has to be familiar with the
content familiar with the technology
famili familiar with the learning
environment I mean there it has to be a
complete piece for the faculty and I
believe that the fac there's disconnect
so part of the activity that I hope we
get to will address that very thing so
I'm hoping that you all can help me with
that piece too because we we have many
check sheets on student preparedness you
know time management all these other
things but I haven't found very much out
there for faculty Readiness to do this
type of thing so I'm hoping you can help
me with this
oh okay hi I'm Ursula woles um and Dan
the answer is of course syntax free
languages are
better cor okay and by the way it's not
just anecdotal I mean the point is not
so much whether they can type or not or
but whether the drag and drop
environment is is um and purely
anecdotal and Dan hasn't heard this
story either I I spent a week working
with aim high students in New Jersey
these are our Elite um inner city kids
who we are spending three weeks on a
campus in order to understand what
college is about in four days they they
did App Inventor apps despite the fact
that the IT staff didn't put the right
software on the machines on the first
day um it's it's very doable um you know
is there definitive research on this
stuff hell no because that's not what
NSF is funding right now I hope
somebody's listening um
but what there's
some right
um please say it again um that it's
teacher preparedness what I've heard
over the last two days here it's not
about the mukes somehow replacing all of
us who have been in the
trenches I'm not at a community college
but I've taught at two middle tier um
first generation American colleges over
the last two years and it's a very
different world from Harvard and MIT and
you're successful if there is there are
prepared teachers willing to really
engage personally with kids or students
or adults who happen to be in your
classroom yeah and nothing works if all
you do is sit at the front of the room
and read the textbook or have them go
home and do the moo right so if that if
we can jumpstart this focus on not a moo
classroom but a Muk supported
classroom that will that will be a big
difference I'd also challenge the
researchers who were in the room the moo
researchers in the room to really start
asking the question about how does the
face Toof face here
interaction support classroom
learning okay that's that's a big one
for me I participated in a moo and the
Forum was wonderful yeah it was really
cool I learned volumes about online
interaction um but this did not did not
compare to the hour and a half my
students and I a bunch of us took the
work together that we put in face to
face right I agree mhm I think this
gentleman she said what I was going to
say oh okay okay great right oh another
question
here we have one more question here in
the
front oh I didn't see oh I'm
sorry I was curious about the student
Readiness process and the faculty
Readiness process and how they're
connected and sort of what you learned
from that and how how Readiness is
measured
well actually that's what I hope we can
do that's what I hope we can accomplish
today only on one aspect we don't have
enough time I wish we had enough time to
tackle all of it but I really want us to
look at faculty Readiness um I believe
the student Readiness part has been
discussed somewhat in some of the
workshops um how much background
knowledge does the student bring into
the classroom um are they familiar with
technology have they had some uh uh uh
experiences with online environments
before so and um there's several check
sheets I know at our University before
for a student can participate in any
online environment they have to go
through an orientation and and the like
but um our faculty really don't have to
do that our faculty really don't have to
go through that preparedness so um I'm
hoping that we can address that faculty
uh Readiness in one of the activities
that I
have thank you two quick things one to
student Readiness we have a tool that we
built that um has student students and I
realize this is really simple self rank
like their ability to do certain things
and then it recommends certain mini
modules for them um and I can I can send
you that afterwards but it's it's kind
of cool but it really relies on students
like
knowing about their own technology
skills which they're not really all the
time good at assessing themselves um but
the other question I wanted to ask and I
don't I don't know if maybe this is a
group question too to your point about
the the synchronous in course inclass
discussion combined with like a some
sort of Muk hybrid model um is anybody
doing synchronous sessions like like a
hybrid model but not a place-based
hybrid model like a like a synchronous
discussion that's not physically
bound um kind of okay cuz we're we're
not yeah um so we have a master's
program in geographic information
systems that has a Capstone course where
students have to prepare a presentation
that they would give at like a National
Conference um and and they actually have
to do that and their advisor goes to the
National Conference and watches them but
in preparation for that part of the
course is that they have to give those
presentations to their peers in the
class and get feedback and have that
interaction um now these are the the
market for most of our programs is work
working adult professionals and they're
all over the globe so we've got a a
setup so you don't have to go to every
student's presentation because that
would be a scheduling nightmare um and
they're done at different times of the
day to try to you know meet and so they
do like four or five of them in an
evening or in an afternoon um and they
are very much required to be there live
and and interact and uh they love it
they seem to really love it they love
that they don't have to go to
everybody's absolutely so I don't know
if that counts as a example of what
you're talking about
abely any any other
comments well great I appreciate the
comments but now let's let's see if we
can work through this now I was asked
about what my thoughts were about
faculty Readiness and I'm hoping that
you can help me because what I found out
being a part of this Workshop is so many
people we're we're asking the same
questions we're really asking a lot of
the same questions we're trying to come
up with the same um uh we're looking for
the same help if you would in order to
do this well so what I'm hoping we can
do is come up with some type of rubric
some type of something that um if
nothing else will start the conversation
on how do we address this faculty
Readiness what is it that the
faculty what what should they possess
what type of knowledge uh should they
have about content knowledge what typ
type of knowledge should they have about
mukes or learning management systems do
they need to possess a whole lot of um
technology skills you know do they have
to be familiar with mobile apps do they
have to um understand the uh background
knowledge of the students that they're
actually trying to interact with should
they be able to understand where they
came from that type of thing so is there
a um a rub that we can use to say this
person should be ready able to move into
that sure
oh there is oh well yeah if
you and share this with everyone been
interest but um in the online world
before moves
sorry sorry thank you um I I'm a pen
State and and we've been doing online
education for a very long time and so
we've gone to Great Lengths to create
rubrics to help faculty assess their
Readiness we even have a tool uh an
online tool where they can kind of score
themselves and and it gives them
feedback on how to better prepare if
they don't feel they're ready but um the
rubric has about 30 items on it and it's
divided into pedagogical competencies
technical competencies and
administrative competencies and I
haven't really looked at it with
thinking of the specifically of a moo
but I having done online education for
since 1998 I can tell you I mean not
much is going to be different so I
wonder what would be specific okay right
Muk world right and I guess my thinking
is from the University setting that I
come from we don't have a large online
component yet you know I'm sure some of
your larger institutions may have an
entire department or something that's
dedicated to this but normally those uh
persons who are in those that faculty
member wants to be there they want to be
a well okay so that's well well maybe
maybe not but I know we have a hard time
on our campus trying to help people buy
into this online environment and if
they're being force fed and see the
problem is if they're being forc fed to
do this and they're not prepared to do
this then the students hate the course
then it's a bad reputation across campus
about the course when it actually was
just the faculty just was not prepared
or was not ready to do that yeah
similarly at Stony Brook um we keep
having these discussions about how do
you make fac interested in this I'm like
we can't even support the faculty who
actually are interested in
it maybe we can table that discussion
for like 10 years down the road well in
just in my small College within the Penn
State University we have 120 online
courses which sounds like we'd have a
lot of Faculty involved and and that is
but we've got a lot more who yeah and I
always say to department heads please
please don't give me someone who doesn't
want to do this because they try to yeah
and they're the worst to work with well
I well then I think that goes back to
the presenter earlier who said if
there's a lot of research out there
share it because I'm because I'm I'm
really yeah and that's perfect but I
would love for us to kind of sit down if
we still could kind of come up with a um
um Baseline you know midline
availability or some type of content
that way and you could just jot down any
ideas that you may have about that or
where they are because it may be of
interest to you with your high schoolers
I mean where where are they and what
type of Readiness do they need to have
in your content knowledge for it to be
successful so if you're saying they have
none some some have none so what's
interesting I'd like everybody to cross
the word facult to say teacher just
because that covers the general space
but the other piece of it is um I feel
like you know the phrase the the the
spirit is willing but the flesh is weak
you know I I kind of look at this is
this is useful these rubrics are useful
not to determine who comes in the door
and who doesn't but for those who do
come in the door it's a checklist here
are the things that we kind of think is
takes to be really good and you're
coming in because you want to be here
you might want to brush up on your
technology skills how to do scripting of
theah blah because that might be needed
at week 17 so that's a useful thing to
do here now they're ready okay I've gone
through the boot camp of the technology
skills piece of it I feel like I've got
all all green lights yeah let's move
move ahead Tuesday and and I think it
there's a question in the
back what I did not include um in my
pyramid was the fact that it would be
unique to each institution too it would
be um something for instance what
happens at buoy State definitely may not
be what's appropriate for someone else
but at least it would give us a baseline
to begin that conversation with faculty
Readiness
Stu I I think this is wonderful but I
also want to caution about having sort
of an entry checklist um and this is I
will do my elevator version of it sure
in December 600 students at the mount
Hein Middle School in Montclair New
Jersey engaged in meaningful computer
science
activities through the Cs week code.org
event um we had 30 teachers
involved their professional development
in understanding how to run snap which
is what Dan works with and the finch
robots from from bird brain
Technologies occurred the day before we
set the kids loose yeah okay if we had
invited teachers in based on you know
are you ready for this we would have had
no teachers including the very gifted um
game development and scratch teacher
true the technology teacher because she
was overwhelmed and she had too much on
her plate and everybody else was like uh
common core standards
test um so I would you know especially
Dan at the high school level I would use
this with great caution the the most
exciting teachers I've had working with
with scratch and snap and now App
Inventor have not been the math
technology teachers um English teacher
music teacher dance teacher um uh uh uh
special education teachers okay
routinely and not because the math
people are aren't interested or don't
have the skills for it they've got a
very different agenda and bringing
Computing in into the high school and in
the middle school has had more to do
with finding people who want to use it
to enhance what what they they teaching
so I'd caution all of you to do this
very very
gently
sure down then
here so um can you bring up the slide
that had the the graph and the
motivation was the Center Bar that was
the highest I I think there's a meta
point there I think that's useful for us
to there that one okay so hard to stay
motivated is the most important thing so
I think if you're going to have not a
checklist but kind of I would have in
your first minute of of any welcome to
Moo is this stuff is hard we're going to
be excited you're going to be engaged
you're going to learn a lot but there
going to be times when you are going to
hit a wall you're going to feel like you
want to give up and to all the folks who
normally drop out we want you to stay
with it when you get to exactly that
minute that we're predicting now is
going to happen to you when that happens
I want you to say it finally happened it
may happen the first 5 minutes may
happen 10 weeks from now but it's going
to happen to you and we want you to stay
with it so the kind of the grit I think
is a metap piece to it right so that's
they the central bar hard to say
motivated that's that that's one of the
keys you got an engaging and Ma like all
the presenters you've seen are so
engaging I want to take classes from all
of you folks right that doesn't happen
if you're limited to a one by one by one
video and you lose so much of the
dynamics of the interpersonal hand on my
shoulder kind of situation that that let
you keep motivated so I think not just
we need to tell our students this but I
think there's some meta now you go to
the last slide there are some meta
things about what you want from and I I
I'm with you that I'm not saying there's
a bar I'm I never said that there's a
bar you have to be green lights on all
10 Dimensions before you can be part of
the Blended space right but there might
be the first if you're having some PD
you said you had some PD for before you
launched them on it there might be some
things you you add to the PD one of them
is this stuff is going to break so let's
just know that stuff is going to break
that that little one sentence like let's
just bear with us as this is new stuff
and it's not going to be easy and blah
blah like there's a little bit of
resilience that the instructor has to be
able to work with and say just bear with
us just saying bear with us isn't on
that list there there's some meta things
that even are more important I think the
grit yeah we may find out 10 years from
now that grid is more important than
background that getting the a in this it
is that when you get stuck do you have a
fixed mindset well I got stck that must
mean I'm dumb I'm going to give up or
DWI might be right all along that I'm
going to dig deep and figure out why did
I mess that question up and do some
background reading maybe 10 Wikipedia
pages and a book here and finally I come
back to that now I can answer the
question let's move on there's you want
that student that might be the most
important thing that students need to
have in successful life what are some of
the things that are listed that might be
the most successful most important
things for a blended instructor
teacher may not be on this list it
that you can handle the fact that you're
out of your element and you're this and
you don't have all the check boxes
they're not all green there's some
yellow there's some red you I'm still
going to persevere and I'm still going
to make this the best experience for my
kids and when the Muk delivered material
is bad or too over our heads we stop the
ability like where on this list is the
ability to know this is too hard for my
kids I need to stop it pull the plug
let's all do an exercise get up and
stretch it that none of that so I think
we need to kind be thinking about the
meta things that are even more important
the formal things that's good I guess I
have one thing to say also the rubric we
can look at it from the the other side
of it when the teachers come in like you
say they have so much to do and I've
taught in the high schools as well you
could use it as a way to understand what
their difficulty may be it's not really
to exclude anybody from the activity but
what is going to be their frustration
level because if there's time for
professional development you have time
to do it versus Thor them in and say
well I didn't know you didn't know
program and I didn't know you didn't
understand Blackboard now you do so you
could use it that way it's is not to
deter anybody is to make this whole
environment much more easier for
everybody alone because if you're not
comfortable it's going to be very hard
to make the students comfortable as well
very I I just wanted to build on on what
you were saying about you know the The
Meta The Meta skills um we do a ton of
professional development for our our
faculty they don't all take us up on it
but um if if they're being hired only
for the purpose of teaching online then
we do make them do it um and I can tell
you over and over again it comes back to
good teaching is good teaching right and
we have many many decades of research we
know what good teaching is and it isn't
unique to technology it isn't unique to
a delivery environment and so I actually
developed a peerreview tool a faculty to
faculty peer review tool um for Penn
States uh use it's it's open anyone can
use it um and it's all built on chering
and gamson's seven principles for
Effective practice in undergraduate
education because good teaching is good
teaching and so even though I was
building this tool about uh peer
evaluation of online courses that didn't
really matter that it was for online and
I think we just need to keep reminding
ourselves of that you know the most
incredible teachers in the face to-face
only face to-face
classroom um can make that Translate
very well to online the ones who are
just really good show people and but
really aren't good teachers they don't
engage with their students are awful
online
because they're the ones who you know
the minute the bell rings they're out of
there and they're avoiding their
students and but the people that I've
met at this conference aren't those kind
of teachers you can hear people saying
oh i r you know earlier today one of the
Pres presenters said I run into my
students in the coffee shop and we talk
those are the really great teachers you
put them in any environment and they'll
be great yeah um I I actually have
something for both of those two things
which is I wrote down effective
characteristics is the first thing for
my tentative rubric before you even said
anything so um and then I thought it was
um um really interesting what you just
said about good teaching is good
teaching because I think the single most
thing about online that we don't we're
not explicit about is that it's an
unforgiving medium and you can't do it
on the Fly and you can't um make it up
as you go along it's a lot harder to
fake it online and so I think making
things specific and explicit it and then
that process of creating the faculty
Readiness maybe if it's not there brings
it back into the classroom so I think
that a really welld designed online
experience in a moo can really inform
future classroom BAS based instruction
and that can be part of this like
faculty feedback loop because you can't
just I mean you have to be able to say
okay we've had this technical issue
we're going to come on or this is really
difficult content let's adjust as we go
being flexible I think is really key but
if you have an unprepared course it is
going to Crater and I think that's you
can you can kind of fake it more in
person still no one will be calling um
you a brilliant instructor but you can
kind of muddle through you can't model
through online that's true so the other
thing I taught amuk uh mik Shel Stony
Brook um and found out later that a
Technical High School in Queens used the
moo for their class and something that I
wish had happened is that that
instructor had actually reached out to
me and been like Hey we're using your
class for this I would have like driven
to Queens and like popped in and be like
hey um so to not
think like worship me yeah so not to
think that it's just a oneway trickle
down thing but if you I mean I I'm like
there's a quiz the first week what how
do you get in touch with your instructor
you do not find them on Facebook and
friend them and then ask them questions
but if it is a whole High School class
that's doing and it would be great to
know how they're doing and highlight
that so to also have the conversation
going both ways right
right in the back
so inspired off of some of the things in
the front about you know what do we want
to put on it um and I'll give you my R
my you need to take these home
yeah um from this conversation these
are I was a department chair you know so
and I hired there was a point where I
had 13 adjuncts and three full-time
faculty and all of that so I've been
there
um to make it successful regardless of
whether whether it's a Muk or not um the
ability to give up control yeah okay
that's that's huge that's huge I I I I
actually take I I I take exception to
the to the preparedness um because I
think that you have to be overprepared
when you're using technology because it
will break that's right you will tap
dance if you're foolish enough not to
walk in any classroom situation without
chalk or whiteboard markers in your in
your pocket I agree you're not prepared
okay so that's that's number three is
chalk or white whiteboard markers in
your pocket yeah um and then the one
that I love best and the one that they
write on my student evaluation forms is
um she says I don't know let's go find
out right okay if you can't do that you
can't you can't teach technology because
you're going to be surprised I
agree and I think part of the um faculty
teacher Readiness is it requires faculty
do a self evaluation too you know it it
requires them to do some reflecting to
say you know I I'm not I don't want to
be prepared most of us don't want a
student to see us unprepared you know
most faculty are not willing to um
relinquish control of the classroom so I
think that's part of all of that that's
going on too great comments any other um
questions or anything anybody want to
share something else that they may have
put on a piece of paper
or
yes or some of your experiences with
your check sheet that'd be that'd be
fine um I just wrote down some URLs that
if anyone would find these helpful
because again we're really into sharing
and I expect to get from from others um
the uh the that competencies for online
teaching that might be helpful um we
also have developed uh three sets of
hiring guidelines that we give to
department heads and
administrators one that says and this is
all in in addition to content expertise
here's what you should look for When
selecting someone to author an online
course one that says in addition to
content expertise here's what you should
look for when you're hiring someone to
teach an online course and then the
third one which may or may not relate to
your needs um here's what you should
look for when uh selecting someone to
oversee an online program yeah okay um
so we've got those if that's of interest
and then um colleagues of mine at State
developed uh that actual self assessment
tool yeah where you go in as an
individual faculty member and you say
yeah this and yeah then you know click
click click click click and it brings
back to you a report that says okay
here's some things you might want to
think about here's some resources um and
and in our case I I believe they Point
specifically to people and online things
for our faculty so that's great if
anyone wants that's
sure any other comments or
questions thank you I think we're a
little bit ahead of schedule but I
appreciate your time and thank
[Applause]
you